you said you and megan went and did
ayahuasca that's a pretty [ __ ]
intense experience was that something
worth doing can you actually learn
something about yourself there was this
one lifetime on the third night i lived
three lifetimes the second lifetime that
i lived
in this in this trip on the third night
was uh i was a a panhandler on the
street i was a beggar
and
in my hand i had this crystal and i kept
offering it
to people
just as energy i kept i kept saying like
you know
like please take this take this good
energy
um like i want you to have it and
they couldn't see that it was a crystal
they just saw it as
me with
like a bowl asking for change like just
begging
and i lived my whole life lonely
and begging on the street and
i had in my hands
love
what all they saw was
a beggar
well that makes perfect sense for me to
you for you to have a vision like that
you had to beg your father for love and
in a sense you were looking for a mother
and in a way as a little kid you
probably felt like can't somebody give
me something i'm out here begging you
i actually never interpreted that one i
always spent time on the other ones that
one i i never thought about like that i
it was almost like i was looking down on
the world being like oh how could you
see
that person like that not see that he
was offering love instead of begging but
yeah that's a good it's a good way to
interpret it that's the person who's
done ayahuasca there's another way to
look at it
yeah that this was a choice
for you
you could live your life that way
or you could choose another path
whoa
whoa
hey so megan went too right did she have
a heavy experience as well
yeah second night is real heavy yeah do
you recommend this kind of thing to
ayahuasca i mean what scared the [ __ ]
out of me i'm i do and you know what i
i i think that we owe so much respect to
the forest and the earth in general like
there's so many answers
and we bypass it because we're made to
seem like oh it's crazy or it's
witchcraft or these these things that
i
really really encourage
if there is anyone out there listening
like there's um i watched this movie it
was called the last forest i believe and
it was about
the yonomami tribe and i it also was
relevant because i just came from south
america and just witnessed like how just
like how much love and care
the people there have
even after all this destruction that
we've caused like all this deforestation
all the cutting to oh dude that we've
poisoned their waters with their rivers
with mercury man like we've killed tens
of thousands of these people
for
gold prospecting
for
for land for tree it's it's not ours and
they still
take
us into their homes and they heal us
i was not around people that looked like
me i was with peruvian shaman who don't
speak english
who are looking at me with my tattoos
and my bleached hair and my jewelry and
and and and being like i i don't
i don't judge i don't see you for
anything other as the soul that needs to
be fixed and i'm going to do that even
though people that look like me have
probably came and ravaged their land
that [ __ ] me up that they would still
give us love
and we can't even just let them live